Transcriber: Lubna Alsalamah
المدقّق: Tarek Mamdouh
يا الّي عالكرسي
الله يعينه، ما بيشوف
يا حرام، أطرش وأخرس
ومو فاهم شو عم يصير حوليه
شوفوا هذا من ذولي
هدول معاقين،
أبصر هالعائلة شو عاملة لربها حتى بلاها
بهيك ولد كذا معاق
لا يوه، شو آخذه معي؟
أستحي فيه قدام العالم
وين ودي أودي هالشيء من العالم؟
والله شيء بيسود الوجه
شو بدهم يقولوا عني؟ عندي ولد
مو بس معه توحد، لا، وكمان فرط نشاط
لك إيه، خلونا نكون واقعيين
إنه أغلبنا سمعنا، أو شفنا، أو حكينا من
هذي المصطلحات وهذي الكلمات
والذنب الأساسي، مو بس إحنا السبب
فيه
سببه عدم وعي مجتمع، وعائلات، وأفراد
زرعوا فينا إن هذول الأشخاص
عيب، وشيء مو زين وجودهم بيننا
وإذا الله “ابتلانا” بواحد منهم كما
يعتقد البعض
لازم نخبيه وما حدا يعرف عنه شيء
أنا منى عمقي، عمري اثنين وثلاثين سنة
بعد كم يوم، بطب عالثلاث والثلاثين سنة
بعرف مو بيبين علي لهيك خلوا الموضوع
بيناتنا
بشتغل بأحد الشركات الخاصة بدمشق بقسم
خدمة الزبائن والسوشل ميديا
ومن جديد صرت بقسم الموارد البشرية
وأسست أحد أهم المبادرات تدعمنا إحنا الي
بينقال عنا معاقين
طالبة جامعية في جامعة دمشق، بعدني ما تخرجت
يمكن لأن لسا ما لقيت حالي بالمكان الي ممكن
أبدع فيه
وحاليًّا، بفكر بالإعلام
معي شوية شهادات محلية ودولية وأصاعيد
الأعمال التطوعية والإنسانية
ما بينحكى فيه، بس بالنسبة إلي شيء كثير
عظيم
وهلأ، خلينا بالموضوع
ذوي الإعاقة، أو المعاقين، أو ذو عاهات،
والكثير من المصطلحات
وكل حدا منا بيحكيها على حسب إدراكه ونظرته
لهذي الفئة من المجتمع
ولكن ما زلنا بنعرف إن التعريف من دول
الأمم المتحدة
هو ذوي الإعاقة
مثل ما تم تعريفه إنهم الأشخاص
الي بيعانوا من مشاكل ذهنية، أو حسية،
أو عقلية
ممكن تمنعهم من المشاركة بصورة كاملة وفعالة
بالمجتمع على قدم المساواة مع الآخرين
بس الإعاقة عندي هي انطلاقة
وإرادة قوية لحتى أوصل لحلمي
وأثبت وجودي بمجتمع لسا بده شوية شغل
ليشوفنا من الزاوية الصح
لهيك، حبينا نغير هالمصطلح ونقول:
أصحاب الهمم
بس، ولكن إذا تجرأت أن تكون مختلفًا
ما عليك إلا أن تكون مستعدًّا للمواجهة
ومعليش، شو خسرانين إذا حكينا هذي
الكلمات الي ممكن تحفز الطرف الثاني؟
وصدقوني، هي كلمة سلسة، وقوية، ومحفزة،
وقريبة للقلب مثل محسوبتكم
وهلأ، بدي أحكي لكم قصة راشد
راشد، بسبب خطأ طبي، صار عنده شلل رباعي
وبقي أربع سنين في بيته منعزل عن الحياة
وأهله لا حول لهم ولا قوة
وحدا من الناس الي بيحبه راشد خبرونا عنه
رحنا بفريقنا التطوعي، الي فيه أشخاص من
أصحاب الهمم، وغير أصحاب الهمم
نتعرف على راشد
وفعلًا، تعرفنا عليه، وخبرناه إنه هو شخص
قادر يكون منتج في المجتمع
وبأثر هذي الكلمات بعد فترة زمنية
راشد صار ينزل وبحضر دوراتنا التدريبية
بمساعدة فريقنا التطوعي
وبعد فترة، أخذ البكالوريا وهلأ هو طالب
جامعة وبينزل وبيحضر محاضراته
مع أصدقاءه الي فيه منهم أشخاص
من فريقنا نفسه
وكمان، ودي أحكي لكم قصة عني
هي قصة الخطابة
فيه عندنا عادة بالشام، وكلنا بنعرفها.
وهي عادة الخطابة
وإنه في كل جمعة نساء أو زيارات بينهم
فيه وحدة بتكون عم بتدور على صبايا للخطبة
ومرة، كنت طالبة بكالوريا، وكنت بأحد
هالزيارات
بتكون فيه وحدة عم تدور على صبايا للخطبة
بتقوم تلتلف علي وتقول لي “ما تؤاخذيني،”
ما فينا نبل عليكِ، ولا نحكي عنك.”
“الله يكون بعونك، ويعلي مراتبك. ونصيبك
بالجنة لأنك معاقة.”
“وطبعًا نخجل نحكي عنك على المحيط والناس
الي حولينا”
بلحظتها، تساءلت مع نفسي
هل إحنا كأصحاب الهمم ما نمتلك مشاعر
أو نفس بشرية
لها حق في الارتباط أو الزواج؟
بس، لثانية،
كان فيه صوت كثير عظيم قدامي
عم يحكي ويجاوب هذي الخطابة ويقول لها:
“أنتِ مو أكرم من الله. وأنا شايفة منى
بمكان كثير كبير”
“وفي مستقبل كبير ناطره”
هذا الصوت، هو صوت أم عظيمة جابتني
على هذي الدنيا
يعني يوم ولدت، الدكاترة قالوا لها:
“ما بتعيش غير سنة، اشبعوا منها”
بس أنا عشت وكملت ولاكني واقفة قدامكم
كثير كنت بتمنى وجود هذي الإنسانة
معنا اليوم
ولكن، شاء رب العالمين أن أفقدها هي ووالدي
من سنين
وأكون مسؤولة عن نفسي وعن حياتي،
بكل تفاصيلها
بس مع هيك،  عم كمل. مثل ما كانت
تقول دايمًا إني أنا رح أوصل
والحمد لله، وصلت.
لهيك رح نتفق مع بعض إن الكلمة الحلوة صدقة
شو خسرانين إذا حكينا كلمة جميلة
بحق الأشخاص الي مقابلينا
لأن إحنا بأثر بكلمة وحدة، ممكن يمتلئ عقلك،
وتتغذى روحك بأثر هذي الكلمات
لأن الكلمة بتفرق
ولأن الكلمة بتفرق، ودي أقول للأهل
أنتم الداعم الأول والأخير إذا كان عندكم
شخص من أصحاب الهمم
ادعموه، وآووه، ووقفوا جنبه
أبدًأ ما تخجلوا فيه وتحسسوه إنه
هو عنده نقص. بالعكس افتخروا فيه
لأن أنتم الدرجة الأولى الي وده يطلع عليها
على الحياة
بالمقابل، ما رح نكون عاطفيين زيادة
وإنه هو حراام، وما بيصيير، وعنده نقص
وما لازم يطلع
لا. خلينا نكون حكيمين بالتصرف والتعامل
لحتى ابننا يوصل للمكان الي هو حابب يوصله
وكمان ودي أقول للمجتمع
نحنا بحاجة لنشر وعي أكثر عن أصحاب الهمم
ونغير مفهوم: “ما لك مكان بيننا”
لمفهوم: “لا، لك مكان بس أدواتك
هي الي بتختلف”
يعني، بدل ما بتحكي بصوتك،
رح تحكي بلغة الإشارة
وبدل ما تحكي برجليك، رح تمشي على كرسي
بعجلات
لهيك واجبي أنا وإنتا وكل حدا مسؤول
إنه نغير هذي النطرة عن الأشخاص
من أصحاب الهمم
وخلينا متأكدين إنه رسالتك غير رسالتي
ويمكن رسالتي كانت محملة بالصبر أكثر
من رسالتك
بس مع هيك بنقدر نغير مجتمعنا
لحتى يصير أفضل
وهلأ بدي أقول لأصدقائي من أصحاب الهمم
يلي عم بحكي عن ربع السكان بعد
اثنتا عشرة سنة من الأزمة
أنا ماني جاية أقول لك إنه الحياة وردية.
وخصوصًا هون
فيه تحديات، وعقبات، وصعوبات،
وشغلات كثير رح تواجهك
ممكن تبكي كثير،
أو ممكن تنجرح من أقرب الناس لك
بس أنت رح تكون قدها. وحنا مثل ما بنعرف
وحسب الدراسات عندنا حساسية زايدة
وهذا الشيء من رب العالمين ما له من عندنأ
بس أنت رح تقدر، وتوصل لحلمك، وتثبت وجودك
برغم أي صعوبات ممكن تواجهك
وختامًا، ودي أقول شكرًا
لأي منصة تسمح لنا نوصل صوتنا
بطريقة صح بعيدًا عن الشفقة
اليوم، أنا منى عمقي وقفت أمامكم عمنصة
تيدإكس
بكرة دور راشد وغيره كثر من أصحاب الهمم
لحتى يكون صوتهم مسموع
ويكونوا جزء من تنمية المجتمع.
أبدًا مو عائق فيه
واليوم كلنا رح نطلع من هذي القاعة
ونكون رح نغير وتفرق معنا الكلمات
ونبدل “ذوي الإعاقة” ل“أصحاب الهمم”
لأن الكلمة تفرق.
وشكرًا.